lindsey vonn ne peut que contempler son
avenir incertain comme les autres
éleveurs de meroux taïwanais il a perdu
d'un seul coup 80% de son marché il y a
deux mois d'octobre times et noir il se
sent prise en otage sans moyens de
défense
le textant des taux de contamination
élevées à certains produits chimiques la
chine a suspendu l'importation du mérou
taïwanais
line sonson crois que la chine espère
que les éleveurs comme lui feront
pression sur leur gouvernement afin
qu'il change ses politiques à l'égard de
la chine
but as raison je vais perdre de l'argent
dit il mais que puis-je faire ils sont
les acheteurs ils imposent leur volonté
et une échelle
de six jeunes making process of 10 mois
précisent les tactiques d'intimidation
économique de la chine contre taïwan ont
pris une toute autre ampleur la semaine
dernière furieuse contre la venue de
nancy pelosi sur l'île la chaîne a
interdit l'importation de thé d'agrumes
et de deux autres sortes de poissons ce
qui a fait que des centaines
d'entreprises la chine a également
suspendu temporairement l'envoi de
terreur à taïwan ce qui pourrait toucher
la production du plus grand joueur
mondial de l'industrie des semi
conducteurs tsmc fournisseurs entre
autres la pole
repenser les débouchés pour les produits
taiwanais
et préparer des dumplings avec les
surplus de meroux un poisson de luxe
dont le prix a chuté en raison de
l'embargo chinois
feng shui fagnan prépare 400 à 500 par
jour à elles seules
beaucoup de jeunes dames paul poisson
dit elle ça va peut-être les encourager
à en manger les produits à base de me
roux ont même contribué à faire
augmenter les ventes d'autres produits
sydenham d'interdiction d'importation du
mir ou en chine a donc offert une
occasion d'affaires exceptionnel pour
cette croix
taîwan produit environ 6000 tonnes de me
roux par année lille ne pourra pas
remplacer à elle seul marché chinois des
éleveurs cherchent à développer de
nouveaux marchés dont le canada que
cathie gauthier hm du coup la méline son
sommet envisagent déjà de réduire du
tiers sa capacité d'élevage l'an
prochain pour limiter les pertes ces
étangs sont sa vie en 40 ans d'élevage
de meroux il n'a jamais été aussi
inquiets ici philippe leblanc
radio-canada cochon dans le sud de l'île
de taïwan